[Música]
[Aplausos]
o un campesino porque nací crecí en el
campo pero no me meten los dedos a la
boca porque me formé como profesional en
las ciencias veterinarias conozco el
campo desde la experiencia hasta los
científicos y por eso puedo decir que en
el campo está todo por hacer esta es una
imagen trabajando con comunidades en el
departamento del cauca en el
departamento donde soy oriundo y donde
lo hacen los dos ríos más importantes de
colombia el cauca y el magdalena reserva
de biósfera por las naciones unidas
tenemos desde la costa hasta el páramo
todos los pisos térmicos para producir
comida para nuestro país y en donde
convivimos negros indígenas y mestizos
una belleza departamento cierto
tenemos una nueva generación y lo que
viene con ellos es un relevo en el campo
que buscamos que nuestras nuevas
generaciones se vean interesadas por las
producir unos alimentos para nuestra
sociedad
en el campo se pueda vivir dignamente y
que podamos como decía el speaker
anterior tener oportunidades
en toda la parte de conocimiento pero
cuál es la realidad el campo está
sumergida en la pobreza y las
oportunidades son muy difíciles el
sector rural
y más aún en nuestro país en donde el 35
por ciento de nuestros campesinos viven
en pobreza 15% en pobreza extrema
será esto será esto posible
tenemos otro gran problema actualmente
más de 200.000 hectáreas están sembradas
con cultivos ilícitos el principal
financiador del conflicto armado y la
corrupción
ya introduciéndonos en nuestro campo
trabajo en la elaboración de alimentos
para animales cuando empiezan todos
estos modelos de producción animal me
doy cuenta que para producir un cerdo
para producir pollos leche huevos el 75
de 75 el 85% de los costos de producción
están en alimentos y esos alimentos son
importados
todo lo que consume nuestros animales
maíz trigo soya viene de países nórdicos
o de argentina
75% de los costos de producción es en
alimentos para esos animales y
dependemos de otros países para que nos
vendan las materias primas para
alimentarlos en donde está nuestra
seguridad alimentaria nuestra soberanía
como pueblos como países
nuestros campesinos están muriendo y
sumergiéndose en la pobreza y nosotros
comprando las materias primas a otros
otros de otros países cuál es su
principal objetivo erradicar el hambre a
nivel mundial
creemos que con nuestros proyectos y con
lo que estamos desarrollando podemos
llegar a sacar de la pobreza a mucha
gente del sector rural y generar un
campo digno en donde existan las
oportunidades y la gente puede vivir en
paz y muy bien económicamente interviene
una nueva ola y en todas las en todos
los modelos de conocimiento nuevos en el
cual en el sector rural se están
generando nuevos cambios desde
reverdecer los desiertos con la
ganadería hasta sembrar cultivos en
ellos que son capaces de sobrevivir a
las condiciones más extremas y por eso
creemos en el campo está todo por hacer
y las nuevas generaciones como los
jóvenes que nos acompañan hoy tienen que
entender es en el campo existen
oportunidades que hacemos nosotros
aprovechamos los con los conocimientos
de nuestros campesinos sembrar trabajar
la tierra sé que no podemos competir con
las grandes maquinarias que trabajan en
otros países pero nosotros en nuestro
trópico lo podemos hacer
como lo hacemos nosotros lo hacemos
enseñándoles a cultivar formas proteicos
por las que crecen como la maleza
por eso son de baja producción no son
transgénicos no químicos ni tienen
hormonas son una belleza para la
nutrición de nuestros animales y
nosotros en el trópico lo podemos
producir a muy bajo costo tienen
excelentes características como una gran
proteína altos en fibra y betacarotenos
y empezamos a hacer con todos estos
trabajos empezamos a convertirlo en una
materia prima lo cosechamos lo picamos y
los hidratamos con todo con todo el
apoyo de nuestro amado sol que le aporta
a nuestras plantas y a nosotros
comenzamos a tecnificar los cultivos y a
trabajar con los campesinos para que
empezaran a convertir esos cultivos en
materias primas para la industria y
comenzamos a meter esa materia prima en
la formulación de nuestros alimentos a
eso me dedico a introducir estos nuevos
elementos en las dietas para cerdos para
bovinos para equinos bajando los costos
de producción y haciendo alimentos más
eficientes y trabajando en algo que
viene más adelante que es los alimentos
orgánicos queremos que ustedes en su
plato puedan comer más adelante
alimentos que sean libres de
transgénicos que sean libres de hormonas
de promotores y químicos y nosotros con
estos forrajes lo estamos logrando
nuestros campesinos ya se encuentran
sembrando y estamos introduciendo en las
dietas por animales todo este tipo de
proteína de origen vegetal que se puede
cultivar en nuestras tierras
y si podemos hablar será que si hacemos
estos modelos podemos revertir lo que
está sucediendo actualmente y generar
soberanía alimentaria a nuestro pueblo
yo creo que si nuestros pueblos son
capaces de producir las materias primas
para alimentar a nuestra misma gente y
lo estamos logrando pero necesitamos el
apoyo de muchas más personas y lo vamos
a lograr
en todas estas investigaciones y en todo
este trabajo desde la academia desde la
experiencia nos dimos cuenta que los
sistemas productivos actuales son de muy
baja rentabilidad por ejemplo una
hectárea sembrada de café en la última
cosecha tan sólo deja mil dólares en un
año de producción eso es increíble
porque no podemos seguir fomentando
proyectos de caficultura cuando no son
sostenibles cuando los cultivos ilícitos
una hectárea es capaz de producir 9 mil
10.000 dólares al año
con los órganos encontramos algo muy
interesante al ser unas plantas que que
son como malezas ellos son capaces de
regenerarse muy rápido y volver a crecer
con mínimo abono con mínimos cuidados y
con la potencia con la potencia que le
pueda dar nuestros productores podemos
lograr que esos forrajes nos produzcan
más de 12 mil dólares al año incluso por
encima de los cultivos ilícitos escuchen
lo que estamos trabajando que hacemos lo
transformamos para introducirlo a las
dietas de animales es lo que hacemos y
lo que nosotros soñamos es un modelo
global tropical en el cual no solo
colombia venezuela brasil sean los que
los que podemos trabajar todas estas
cosas sabemos de los índices de hambre y
de pobreza en etiopía somalia kenia
países que están en el mismo trópico y
que como podemos empezar a trabajar para
también generar alimentos alimentos
sobre este asiático por eso tengo un
sueño tengo un sueño de ver a las
comunidades del mundo no dependiendo de
terceros y no copien más los modelos de
nutrición y producción americanos o
argentinos para alimentar los animales
sino que desde sus pueblos sean capaces
de generar su propia
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]